hey everybody it's katie oh and that's
my husband chris hi i'm chris i'm
obviously not in the tasty kitchen um
because we are right now all of
california uh is under quarantine so
tasty and all the other people at
buzzfeed are working from home so we're
still going to be making as many videos
as we can for you guys based on stuff we
have in our kitchen with that said we've
been doing this for about a week and the
days are kind of getting a little bit
like all the same to you know kind of
break up the monotony is i would do a
date night tonight
for us
and i'm only going to use what's in our
pantry i'm going to get going i like all
day to do it nah
yeah
you're going to give me a kiss yeah
don't you dare
so the first course um it's more like a
snack but i have these garbanzo beans or
chickpeas as they are called i'm gonna
make hummus i'm just gonna strain the
garbanzo beans rinse these guys
hold on to this juice because we are
gonna use this in our other recipes
because since we have limited resources
right now i'm just trying to make one
can go as far as it can go save the
juice now that those are rinsed we're
just gonna place them into our blender
then we're gonna add our salts cumin one
or two cloves of minced garlic and blend
this baby up while this is blending
you're gonna add in two tablespoons of
fresh lemon juice a quarter cup of water
and two tablespoons of olive oil
and we have
hummus
yeah
look at that
now we're gonna plate it a lot of hummus
recipes usually use tahini this one does
not it just i didn't have any in the
pantry when plating this to make it a
little fancy
you can take a spoon
and do some swirls once you finish with
your spoon take a little bit of olive
oil and i'm just gonna
do a little bit around not too much
paprika for color bam cover this and
we're gonna put it in the fridge while
we make our next recipe
now i'm gonna make a four ingredient
peanut butter cookie i had a huge like a
huge like i should just show you the jar
here's this huge jar had so much of it i
i was like i should make a dessert with
this so oh
i hit my finger ow so let's get started
first ingredient that we're gonna do
peanut butter i have crunchy peanut
butter this recipe would honestly work
better with smooth but i am using what i
have next we're gonna add a half a cup
of sugar our third ingredient is gonna
be that juice from the garbanzo bean can
it's also called aquafaba this is used
in a lot of vegan recipes as an egg
substitute so add three tablespoons of
aquafaba and we're gonna get
to blending it up and this is basically
it for the recipe those ingredients and
then i'm going to melt some chocolate
later to add a little decoration
all right we're just going to take
a golf ball size and this is going to be
this is going gonna be a little sticky
so you're gonna set that down and i
actually have these crystal coasters and
they have this really
neat design on the bottom of them so
i've washed them and i'm gonna press the
cookie down
oh baby
if you do not have a crystal coaster
with a cool design because not everyone
has that um you can take a fork all you
do is press down one way and then across
the other way you kind of make this nice
little grid pattern
last one is done
we're going to put this in the fridge
no we're not
we're going to bake it oh my god
these guys are going to go in the oven
at 350 degrees fahrenheit for about
eight to ten minutes whoa
these cookies have baked they have
cooled and they are ready
for their fourth ingredient which is
none other than chocolate take one of
our beautiful little cookies
we're gonna dip about half of it into
our chocolate and we're done with our
cookies i definitely already
ate one
i thought it would be kind of romantic
to make pasta a lot of rich pastas like
ones i've made in the past it uses a lot
of egg yolks and actually we're not
going to use any eggs so this is
technically a vegan pasta
we have a half a cup remaining of our
aquafaba so we've used that garbanzo
bean can for hummus for cookies and now
we're going to use it for pasta so today
we're going to use
all-purpose flour
a teaspoon of salt and once that's nice
and mixed up
i'm just going to take the base of a
bowl and i'm just going to make a well
in the center now i have a half a cup of
the aquafaba and i have our olive oil
i just want to combine
the juice with the oil pour that into
the center
and we're going to slowly bring in
the edges of the flower into our
aquafaba oil mixture
[Music]
and now this is really starting to come
together kind of like almost a shaggy
dough i'm gonna take this out
and put it on our surface here and then
work it and knead it
together and any flour that is just not
incorporating into
the dough after a while i'm just gonna
move those off to the side
just so that i don't get a bunch of dry
clumps in my dough and you're going to
keep kneading it so gently
you're going to push in
and out and i like to rotate as i go so
basically you're just gonna keep
kneading it
until your arm wants to die there's also
the heart method of doing this you go
away from yourself you come back
but you go away from yourself you come
back away
back
we're done
look at our little pasta boy
we're gonna cover him in some plastic
wrap so
let that sit for 30 minutes at room temp
in your house and we'll be back okay our
dough is nice and soft i'm gonna cut
this guy in half make sure you wrap up
the other dough so that it doesn't dry
out and then i'm going to try to shape
it in as much of a
kind of rectangle
shape as i can before i start rolling
this out
once it's thinner but not crazy thin
we're just gonna do
this this is also gonna help us get that
rectangular shape
and work the pasta dough
oh
hold my arms hurt this is good i need to
exercise anyway so boom
okay
i have rolled that out pretty thin fold
one end to the center and another end to
the center and i'm gonna fold that again
boom you can take a knife i have this
bench scraper so i'm going to use that
to cut my slices i'm doing fettuccine so
they're a little bit thicker
and then you're going to unroll your
pasta
and there you go
a feta cheese
once you have all of your pasta unfolded
toss in a little bit of flour that way
it keeps it from sticking together i'm
gonna repeat this with my other part of
the dough and then i'm making sauce and
then we're gonna eat be back
boo we're in a new place in my house
that's where the stove is it's where the
fridge is final thing we're gonna do is
make a lemon alfredo sauce first thing
we're gonna do is melt two tablespoons
of butter
add in some minced garlic cook this
garlic until it's fragrant add two
tablespoons of flour and we're gonna use
a whisk
to mix that up
you're just going to incorporate the
flour and the butter let this cook for a
few minutes just so that we can cook the
flour taste out of it once your mixture
is bubbling we're going to slowly
whisk in
warm milk and we're using a whisk so it
can help get out those clumps
there we go
final bit
bring this mixture up to a low simmer
and then we're going to let it thicken
up which is going to take about like
five to seven minutes this sauce has
gotten nice and thick i'm gonna turn off
the heat add in some parmesan salt
pepper
mix that in
oh
this is gonna be good add in a zest of
one lemon mix that in we're gonna slowly
slowly pour in lemon juice you wanna do
this slowly as you whisk
okay perfect
now that our sauce is ready we're going
to throw in our pasta
this only needs like 60 seconds i'm also
gonna throw in some frozen peas i'm
gonna reserve a little bit of the pasta
water before i strain it add a little
bit of this pasta water into here
and loosen it up a bit add in the pasta
and your peas gently mix them into that
sauce
it's time for a romantic dinner for two
okay
[Music]
opening course we've got the hummus i
have cut up celery sticks and carrots
that i was using for stews we've got
this beautiful lemon alfredo sauce with
handmade pasta and some frozen peas
finally
for dessert we have those peanut butter
chocolate cookies oh i put lipstick on
too
yeah okay chris oh wow this looks
amazing
that looks like fancy hummus that looks
like uh fancier than store-bought hummus
i would say oh fancier than santorini
did you notice anything
yeah you got lipstick on i'm wearing
lamps
do i have any yeah you definitely do
before we go watch our hands
we just wanted to say have a great night
i hope that you find time for some type
of date night even a date with yourself
i know some people are by themselves
right now and i hope you feel like we're
with you i feel really lucky that we had
enough in our pantry we could
make something that you can make this
this looks really good um it's just
really nice thing you did and i love you
oh my god i love you too if you kiss me
with my own lipstick
yeah you do this you can see it on the
camera no it's not gonna one second
[Music]
you